[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast our topic today is vitamin d
vitamin d deficiency and the kovid 19
pandemic my guests are dr linda benskin
a nurse researcher and wound specialist
her independent research is on wound
healing in remote and conflict areas in
the tropics she is currently in jamaica
running a randomized controlled trial on
improvised wound dressing
and gareth davis known as gruff who has
a bachelor's in physics and a phd in
medical physics from imperial college
he's best known as an entrepreneur
software engineer and an expert in data
analysis and machine learning he has
consulted for the nhs
let's have a listen
linda gruff welcome to the dark horse
podcast i'm so glad to have you here you
are
experts in a topic that is rapidly
becoming very important to me and many
others who are interested in addressing
our covid situation
vitamin d is the topic
now as i understand it the two of you
have collaborated now but you did not
know each other at the beginning of the
pandemic how did you uh how did you find
each other
well originally i believe it was because
linda wrote an incredible
review early on in the pandemic of all
of the available research and she cited
a publication a pre-print publication
that i'd collaborated on with two
doctors here in london
and i believe that's when we first
met each other because i think i
probably wrote to you to say thank you
and how amazing the the review was
compared to
um the reviews that the uk government
was
not doing so
yeah that uh that review came out of a
frustration of
over and over again public health
officials saying there's just not enough
evidence to make a decision about
vitamin d and this was in
already in may i was writing this
article because it was so clear that the
evidence was already overwhelming in may
of 2020
and so i came across uh gruff's um
causal inference model
and then another causal model using
hill's criteria which is well
established and accepted
by dr baucher which was um
a model that
was used to prove that smoking causes
cancer because
that has the same ethical dilemma of
doing randomized control trials that
vitamin d has you can't really do
a randomized controlled trial if you
really believe that smoking causes
cancer and force half the people in your
group to smoke and the other have to not
smoke in the same way if you really
believe that vitamin d deficiency is
causing people to die of cover 19
you can't tell half of the group
that you're studying you are not
permitted to have any vitamin d
supplements
and you know we're just going to
relegate you to the group that we think
is going to die
so um
the
refs model was a a really interesting
one as well and then i believe he
probably from there hooked me into uh
this ad hoc
uh email list that had
about um
probably at this point 50 experts from
around the world
who uh just share articles and and
insights and information and that that
group has continued to this day
uh
we send the emails to each other every
few days with the latest research that
we've found
and uh
from there when they started the vitamin
d for all letter
uh
i feel like one of my gifts is to be
able to make things more succinct and
more understandable more readable
so i i distill down
research into something that's more
distinct more more readable and
and so i
helped smooth over and helped with the
editing on that letter and can you uh
tell the audience what that letter is
so right you wanna
i think it's uh
worth bringing it up so that i don't um
forget the details
it's called it's vitamin d for all.org
dot org exactly yeah
dotnet.com
and it's a call from scientists and
doctors
around the world we were very selective
we didn't just try and get as many
signatures as possible we went
specifically to the most reputable
eminent professors doctors phds many are
both
medical doctors and phds
because we wanted to
emphasize that the evidence is not just
um
incredibly large but is believed by
people who have strong reputations as
scientists
and we acquired i think 220 signatures
in the end we decided to stop looking
after that
and we have um
uh including david sinclair who's one of
the world's top 50 most influential
scientists so it was one of the last
signatures and the point of that letter
was to
appeal really a call to action to
government
health agencies
and
anyone working in healthcare to take
vitamin d seriously look at the evidence
and present the evidence both for the
efficacy of vitamin d in treating kovid
which is very strong
and also the safety of vitamin d at the
levels that we're recommending because
we found that certain
agents health agencies particularly kept
promoting a message of a very low
amount of vitamin d which is suitable
for bone health but which
won't do anything for immune function
and of course the response to your
letter is that um
health agencies across the world
embraced this and are now recommending
high doses of vitamin d and of course
the harm of the pandemic has been
greatly reduced by these increased
levels of vitamin d especially in the
temperate zones where people are
chronically vitamin d deficient is that
correct that is not the case
unfortunately possibly ireland is one of
the few countries that may that looks
like it's taking things seriously we
were i mean from the beginning from
march uh when we started campaigning
because people around the world were a
number of scientists and doctors around
the world who had enough information and
could synthesize or understand the data
well enough to see what was
what was to mean almost as clear as a
color in the data i'm very experienced
at interpreting data and i can um and i
saw something i it was just blindingly
obvious as a physicist i think
the problem with statistics especially
medical statistics is it teaches
correlation isn't causation but it
doesn't tell you what causation is so of
course you know in physics we don't have
randomized control trials to
do work on astronomy for example you
can't do do a trial on a on a distant
star so we're very used to working with
different methods of inferring chords
um so i would i will just say for for my
audience they are well familiar with
heather and my frustration at the idea
that the only kind of scientifically
reliable inference comes from randomized
controlled trials and there are really
two problems with this one
randomized controlled trials if they are
done well do provide a high quality kind
of evidence
yeah but they can of course be done
poorly and they can give you false
confidence in something because they are
subject to systematic biases
and
the second thing uh
is
that
most of what we know about the universe
did not come through a randomized
controlled trial there are
ethical concerns as linda points out you
can't assign people to smoke if you
believe that it's likely harmful so
randomized controlled trial is out of
the question
there are historical inferences that one
must make in evolution it's very hard
to look at the you know the radiation of
extinct species let's say with
randomized controlled trial this is not
how we learned about plate tectonics
it's not how we learned about newtonian
physics the the fact is randomized
controlled trials are a
luxury
that requires great care to properly
derive inference from them but we are
not
uh scientifically hobbled
by their absence and so when you say
you're expert in
uh in the question of
uh
inference
what you're really saying is that you
see something in the evidence that is
unambiguous and for some reason
you and did you say something more than
200 signatories to
your yeah by the end of uh by the
beginning of this year i suppose it was
early january we were a bit late
publishing it we were hoping to get it
out but it took a long time to to get
there so um but by the
beginning i think or the end of january
this year we had 220 signatures and it
went to
it went to you know we got it seen at
senior levels in governments around the
world including the uk
and it has almost entirely been ignored
so i i want to uh unpack this a little
bit
it is likely true that people who have
not
got a lot of familiarity with vitamin d
as i did not until
covet i thought okay i understand that
this is a vitamin it's probably a
co-factor in certain processes it's
probably
uh something that most of us get enough
of in our food and maybe you're a little
bit deficient and so some
supplementation
is necessary i was aware that it was
produced in the skin uh due to exposure
to sunlight i was probably
concerned that because i know it's a fat
soluble vitamin and fat soluble vitamins
are famously more dangerous than
water-soluble vitamins because one could
take too much
that one has to be cautious about
supplementation and all of these things
and the more i have looked into the
literature the more i've realized that
my model here
was way off and that that was misleading
me now it's possible that
health authorities were misled in this
way and it is possible also that their
caution about vitamin d in light of
these many signatories to this letter
could be about the danger of vitamin d
in other words if vitamin d overdose was
a significant risk you can imagine
public health authorities advising
nothing or advising against
supplementation because the the risk
could be greater than the benefit
what is the the case with respect to
vitamin d toxicity and any reason to be
cautious about administering it
yeah i actually uh addressed that rather
directly
in my more recent uh paper so i did the
basic review and that was published
finally i i submitted the first
iteration of that on may 13th of 2020 i
just got through looking it up and it
wasn't published until september
uh there were a lot of reasons for that
some of them rather nefarious but
september of what year 2020
so it took it took about four months for
it to go through the uh usually very
rapid peer review process frontiers in
public health so then after that basic
review was published
uh by this year
in about may or june i was starting to
sense that that we really needed another
review
because
we were getting uh systematic reviews
but as you know systematic reviews only
take the best of the best
of the research publications and they
don't take into account the big problem
with vitamin d having publication bias
so they don't include anything that's a
preprint and i wanted to do another
review of
all the evidence for vitamin d but this
time i was looking at the evidence
only that was causal or that was my big
emphasis i did uh
tables of evidence for uh review papers
meta-analyses and systematic analyses
and for uh
causal evidence and that's and that was
where i was going with it but i put a
big emphasis at the beginning of that
chapter
on
the uh
whole issue of how you get vitamin d and
the fact that toxicity is not really an
issue so at this point looking at your
public health officials
and what they should know about vitamin
d by now a year ago hamlin's razor might
have applied
but at this point i think there's no
excuse for their ignorance i think that
at this point we have to say that public
health officials who are still
not recommending vitamin d or
intentionally ignored overs
so this is
this is an extremely uh
inflammatory
accusation
now
i know because i have been tracking the
very same question
that the degree to which public health
authorities fail to recommend that which
works
and continue to recommend things that
either do not work or are risky
that it if you start with the model
of
public health authorities let's say
we've got three different models
public health authorities are basically
competent and they're doing as well as
they can in light of an emerging
situation
public health authorities are
incompetent and they are doing as well
as they can which isn't very well at all
or public health authorities are
actively doing that which prolongs the
pandemic
and causes
covid to continue to spread
actually the third model is the most
predictive
it is surprising i can't imagine why
anyone would want this and i am
continually looking for that sign
that in fact this is it you know it
would be better if it was incompetence
because at least we can do something
about that the problem is incompetence
just doesn't explain it and vitamin d to
me
is the obvious proof of this because
when you look into
the truth of vitamin d as is beautifully
presented in your most recent paper
which i have
here
it turns out that the fears that we
might have about vitamin d are
ill-founded they are in fact based on an
over-extrapolation of what happens with
vitamin a
right vitamin a which is fat soluble and
we all learn in biology that in fact
hypervitaminosis a is a possibility
there's a famous case in which an
explorer ate nothing but uh
polar bear uh too much polar bear liver
and the soles of his feet fell off and
so anyway this is an example that is
used to tell people that uh fat soluble
vitamins have to be treated with care
what is the truth
yeah i think the good counter to that is
the example that's in my paper of the
dairy up in the boston area
where the uh dairy accidentally was
fortifying their milk with 525
times
the amount of vitamin d that they
thought they were that they anticipated
giving and putting in the milk so for
two years
the people who were purchasing milk from
this dairy were drinking milk that had
this huge amount of vitamin d in it just
like i said way more than what they
possibly should be getting and did any
of them survive
and in fact they had zero deaths
they had only 19 people who were
symptomatic for vitamin d
in that entire period of time a boston
emergency room finally kind of connected
the dots because people started having
kidney stone kind of issues
and
as soon as they figured out the problem
the
dairy was notified the customers were
notified people stopped taking so much
vitamin d
and the only fatality that resulted from
the entire incident was one particular
patient whose doctor prescribed high
doses of prednisone
to counteract the vitamin d rather than
just
doing some more modest measures and the
person died of a massive infection from
immunosuppression from the prednisone
which the jury said had absolutely
nothing to do with the vitamin
now for the d majority of people it's
extremely hard to overdose on vitamin d
it's a carefully regulated part of the
immune system and of course
plenty of enzymes that start ramping up
to get rid of it if you have too much
because we produce it not a vitamin we
produce it in our skin in certain uh
bands of uv light which you get at most
sort of peak summer time
um and of course
half an hour of
summer sunshine in the middle of the day
full body sunshine will generate about
10 000 international units of
vitamin d
uh
it's not linear so you don't keep doing
10 000 every half an hour it steadies
off but you know we've evolved over
millions and millions of years most
animals all animals as far as i know uh
have vitamin d receptors and british
mammals certainly will produce vitamin d
um and
so our bodies know how to deal with it
it's
it's because we produce it in the skin
it's not like vitamin a where you take
it in through food
and it's actually that only vitamin a i
believe is the toxic fat soluble vitamin
it was assumed that d e a and k would
all be accrued like that but in fact
it's only vitamin a that is really
dangerous this is fascinating so vitamin
a is
uh the exception not the rule the fact
that vitamin d is fat soluble is
irrelevant to the question of overdose
and i learned from you both in our
preliminary conversation
that basically there is a mechanism that
maintains a healthy equilibrium in an
individual that is producing enough
vitamin d which is not most of us in
light of the effect that modern life has
on our encounter with the sun
but the point is were you to take too
much it's not that you would be stuck
with it there is a disassembly mechanism
just as there is a synthesis
mechanism in fact
that that disassembly mechanism can
create a lot of problems for randomized
controlled trials
and uh for interpretation of data in
general and i think that is innocent
that a lot of people have misinterpreted
uh bolus doses so
a lot of times for these trials there's
a famous study in brazil uh during cover
19 in which they wanted to show whether
or not vitamin d would help with
seriously ill
hospitalized covet 19 patients and my
area of expertise there is evaluating
the
study design of researches to find out
how they should appropriately be applied
and
in this particular study design was a
rather poor one because they gave
vitamin d extremely late and they gave
the precursor to the precursor to the
active vitamin d
so but the important point here
is that when you give a very large
one-time dose of vitamin d
that kicks in that fail-safe mechanism
and causes the bi the body to break down
that vitamin d and in fact the body will
continue to break down vitamin d for 28
more days
so you end up actually having a lower
vitamin d
a week later than what you would have
had if you hadn't gotten vitamin d at
all
and the other problem is that the tests
that are used to test for serum vitamin
d in the blood don't distinguish between
the active vitamin d
and that
breakdown product
so these researchers in brazil when they
tested the serum levels of these
patients said oh look but we know that
the bolus worked because their vitamin d
levels in their blood were high
whereas
likely we have no way of knowing because
it's not a very commonly used test to
distinguish between those what they
actually were finding is the breakdown
product was high not the active vitamin
d level was high and that is the
only study that the us government has
cited
relating
in
in discussing vitamin d and cover 19. so
all the other studies that showed that
vitamin d worked well
uh there were three studies out of spain
there were several from france there
were a lot of different prospective
studies
that showed that vitamin d dramatically
decreased
covid case rates covet hospitalizations
coveted death rates coveted icu rates
all of those things were dramatically
reduced when people had vitamin d prior
to getting cover 19 or early on when
they first got cop19 all of those were
not even mentioned by these government
organizations instead they mentioned
only this brazilian study in which they
gave this huge bolus dose that probably
actually served to drop the vitamin d
and actually it wasn't even a
particularly big dose it was uh in the
end it was
only raised
and you know if you throw a bucket of
water on a blazing house fire you don't
then and it doesn't put the house fire
out you don't then report water doesn't
put out fires right it's it's just like
that in a disease if you act
you can put the fire out so this is a
perfect indication of what we are saying
that despite the fact that
none of the three of us would leap to
the conclusion that public health
authorities were actively
somehow seeking not to control covid but
in this case to take all of the evidence
that vitamin d positively affects
covered outcomes prevents contraction of
the disease and positively affects
outcomes and those who contract the
disease to focus on the study that fails
to point to that result because of an
experimental design flaw is what you
would predict if you were looking to
avoid this conclusion somehow rather
than to figure out what was going on and
and to navigate as best as possible
yeah so i wanna i wanna uh stop you for
a second because
most people don't know anything
really about vitamin d
can we talk a little bit about normal
the normal interaction between human
beings and vitamin d how it is supposed
to work and then what modern life has
done to that interaction and then what
implications it has for disease
yeah i think it's worth probably given
that you you you look through the
evolutionary lens it's a very good way
of looking at uh what was vitamin d like
you know 10 000 years ago for for us
as a species well and actually there
have been studies that have looked to
try to find tribes that live that way
now still and measure their serum levels
and they're great really clever studies
because they show us what our normal
serum levels should be
and they're far far higher than the
levels that are currently defined as
sufficient uh in almost across the board
so we now everybody who's part of this
community is pretty much on board now
with
a level that we would target for
ourselves of 50 nanograms per milliliter
using the american units we use slightly
different units here in new europe so
out by which you have to multiply by two
and a half
um and yeah because you're out in the
sun the summer sun all the time getting
exposed all day when it's sunny
yeah so what i talk about in my paper is
the indoor lifestyle that we now have
which is absolutely not uh what any of
our predecessors had and the change was
during the industrial revolution
so prior to the industrial revolution
virtually everyone in the world
hunted gathered fished or farmed and so
they were outside all day including in
the heat of the day now it's important
to know that vitamin d is not obtained
from the sun just anytime anywhere
so uh
the rule of thumb is that if the sun is
not at least 45 degrees above the
horizon
you are not going to be able to get any
vitamin d because the ozone in the and
this is you know historically the ozone
in the air the natural
uh
atmosphere is thick enough that the uvb
rays don't get to you so you can still
get sunburn from the vitamin from the
uva rays but the uv b rays that help
provide vitamin d are not accessible to
you so what i tell people is
if you want to know if you're getting
vitamin d or not it's very simple
when you're outside look at the ground
at your shadow if your shadow is not
sharp and shorter than you are tall you
are not getting significant amounts of
vitamin d that's beautiful early morning
outside is a wonderful time
enjoy the birds but you're not getting
vitamin d
winter middle of the day if you live in
a northern climate you're not getting
vitamin d
so it this is a and there are actually
uh pretty easy to find uh apps
and uh places you can go on the internet
where you can find out what the angle of
the sun is in your particular location
to find out whether or not you can get
vitamin d today or not but at this time
of year there is no place in the united
states that you can get vitamin d even
in the middle of the day so it's also
ultimate pollution as well so it's worth
knowing that you might all those
conditions can be present and you still
might not be getting enough so
absolutely air pollution
i take a daily supplement every day all
year round i just take more in winter
than i do in summer so
i'm also now taking uh daily supplements
as as is heather i'm i'm is uh
d minder a good app for people to use we
have recommended it isn't it
okay
a charity that was set up years ago and
they have some fantastic information for
people it's aimed at uh promoting
information it's called grassroots
because they've actually been
campaigning for more than 10 years to
try and get vitamin d somewhere here in
the uk and failing and in the end
decided we just have to educate people
because the governments aren't going to
help us get this message out and are
actively resisting it and have done for
a decade so
i want to point out the
uh what may still be subtle for people
which is
in almost any ancestral circumstance
the amount of outdoor
time
during the summer
would result in a production of
sufficient vitamin d which would then be
stored
in
fat
and muscles yeah stored in muscles as
well so yeah it diffuses too also
basically across your entire weight all
right so
the
stuff stored in fat and muscle in
particular has a special relevance
because basically we have an ebb and
flow of
available food resources in ancestral
circumstances and so what you have is an
elegant system for banking vitamin d
when it's easy to produce because the
sun is high
and storing it in fat which will
therefore then be released as times are
tougher less is growing and there's less
sunlight so the point is it's a system
that is built to maintain an equilibrium
and those of us who are supplementing to
compensate for the fact that we are now
spending much more time indoors and i
should point out that there are some uh
counter-intuitive aspects of this like
window glass blocks uv
radiation and therefore even if you're
sitting in the window seat and it's
the sun is shining on you it's not doing
you any good in this regard
it's sunscreen doesn't take really any
sunscreen at all to block the uvb rays
as well
sunscreen and uh you know i was
realizing um i'm a cyclist and i
realized that even in the summer when it
might be better to cycle with a shirt
off the cultural custom seems to be to
wear a shirt and that that's probably
something that we ought to revise at
least maybe shortening sleeves or
something would allow more production
correct the other thing we're seeing is
that the tropics you'll notice if you
look at cova 19 rates
all throughout sub-saharan africa you're
just not finding the coca-19 rates and
we were expecting it to be catastrophic
in sub-saharan africa because there's so
little capacity i lived for five years
in a remote area of ghana
and that is a very outdoor culture the
people basically use their huts as a
place to shelter to protect themselves
from dangers at night when they are
asleep yeah they spend the entire day
outside they eat out aside they visit
outside they cook outside
and in those areas we're just not seeing
cova 19. i've got friends who work in
hospitals and clinics there and they're
just not seeing it and they should be
and i believe it's because their vitamin
d levels are high
but
in the areas that are uh heavily islamic
or have other cultural reasons so for
instance cambodia and the philippines i
know for a fact and in brazil to a
lesser extent uh light skin is highly
valued and so people tend to cover up
especially the women tend to be covered
up and that's where we're seeing the
outbreaks along the equator it's places
where
people are wearing a lot of clothing
even though they're in the tropics so
this is exactly what happened with mers
do you remember mers of course the
middle east respiratory syndrome uh and
and it was in fact when i did my
literature review at the very beginning
of the pandemic to look into uh previous
coronaviruses and seasonality it was one
of the first things that stood out and
it was
targeting exactly the same people who
wore full body clothing didn't get
exposed to natural sunlight and were
vitamin d deficient
and when i did the causal inference
analysis we looked at
i think it's probably the biggest causal
inference analysis ever conducted we
looked at 1.4 million data points
because there was so much data coming
out at that time
and
examined the geographic patterns
the virus was in
australia for example all over the the
centre of the the tropics well before it
hit italy and yet there were no severe
outbreaks anywhere
until it hit italy all of the
um locations that suddenly started
having severe outbreaks were happening
north of pretty much north of 40 degrees
uh north last year uh
a couple of exceptions were 30 degrees
so i i noticed early in the pandemic uh
the
disaster that unfolded in guayaquil
ecuador um
now this is anomalous because of course
ecuador means equator and so from the
point of view of the angle of the sun
it's the perfect place to be guayaquil
is on the coast it's a low area but it
is very
hot
and i don't know maybe you know the
answer but i'm wondering if the
prevalence of air conditioners and the
tendency of people to be driven indoors
by
uh heat might have contributed in
guayaquil compared to for example quito
which is at high altitude and a much
more temperate climate um where two
factors that that might be at play there
one is that there's
a genetic polymorphism which is which
interferes with vitamin d production in
communities in ecuador
uh i i'm not the expert on that
particular thing but i'm in touch with
one scientist who is and the other
explanation as you've said is in in very
hot weather this happened actually in
arizona as well i was very surprised to
see rates going up in arizona because
the temperature was so high it was 40
degrees centigrade which is i don't know
what in fahrenheit like a billion
fahrenheit yeah
and so of course that's that whole
everybody goes straight to the mall
whereas and then air conditioning you
you know an air conditioning wall is
perfect breeding ground for
it's dry and it's cold and it and that's
perfect uh transmission time you were
talking about italy earlier in italy's
early uh
pandemic and the surprising thing with
italy and you could see the same thing
in korea
that
in both italy and korea you would expect
the biggest outbreaks to be in the
biggest cities that have the
international airports
so you would expect rome to be where the
italian outbreak was but it wasn't
instead the italian outbreak was up
north
and in the mountains the same thing
happened in korea seoul did not have the
big outbreak the big outbreak was in a
smaller city
and people looked at the air pollution
levels across those countries and the
air pollution
was such that
both seoul and rome the way that they
sit on the coast
the same thing happens with houston
texas
the the currents push the air pollution
inlet
and so those areas don't have high air
pollution unlike
california where the california coast
has the mountains right behind it and
california coast has serious air
pollution right along the coast and so
they found that air pollution was a
really high uh risk factor for getting
uh coveted 19 and wuhan has incredible
problems with air pollution
so is the uh i guess maybe
because they both point in the same
direction air pollution on the one hand
blocks uh uv radiation
also it will tend to drive people
indoors where they have at least some
insulation from it um well you you're
not if you're if you're living in a
really heavily polluted city there's
really no way to get away from it you
know that we're we're
talking about
uh
people that don't necessarily have hipaa
air filters inside their houses so um
notice that in brazil for example that
was one of the
southern countries that seemed to start
to have a big outbreak and did have a
problem
and that was surprising to people
brazil actually has a very well
documented vitamin d deficiency problem
in its older communities which of course
you know older people they're usually
housebound or in a home and they're not
out in the sun getting uh and there's a
very
high uh population that are either
black or mixed race uh and
you know that your skin color will also
block uv so
early in the pandemic when i was working
with um dr grammy and dr buyers we we
predicted that we would see if we were
right we would start seeing higher
fatality rates in people with dark skin
and as that happened they were being
announced on the news it was another
data point that said we write about this
and it was just incredibly hard to get
people to take that seriously
um
which is pretty sad yes it's a it's a
politically incorrect conclusion that
there is something physiologically
predisposing darker-skinned people to
risk from covid the irony is that
recognizing
the reason that dark-skinned people have
dark skin is to block uv radiation and
so it is not surprising in an era where
people have been moved around so they
don't live where their ancestors were
and their skin color does not
necessarily match the amount of
encounter with uv radiation that they
have that therefore being aware that it
blocks vitamin d production and
supplementing to compensate for and
supplementing i would point out can
mean taking a vitamin d supplement it
can also mean minding the position of
the sun and very actively banking
vitamin d which is uh to my way of
thinking a much better although i am now
forced to supplement uh with diet
banking it from the sun would be a far
superior mechanism is that is that fair
to say yes and and here in jamaica uh
i've done a lot of education with the
people here
on the time of day that they need to be
out in the sun because uh obviously it's
hotter and not as pleasant in the middle
of the day and so if they're not a
farmer or a fisherman
they have no need to be out in the sun
in the heat of the day
and so we've
done a lot of education with them saying
you know it's going to take some time
even here in the tropics for you to get
enough vitamin d and you need to be out
there
fortunately here in jamaica it's like
between 9 a.m and 3 p.m there's a pretty
big window of time that they can be out
in the sun but it's already hot at eight
so um so you're exactly right and my
paper the original one the basic review
paper
i
had a hard time getting them to assign
my final peer reviewer it was yeah the
other peer reviewers
finally approved it in the middle of
august and then i couldn't get a final
peer reviewer to be assigned and it just
languished and then as soon as i got
that final peer reviewer assigned the
very next day she approved it and it was
ready to be published i thought because
every other time i've published a paper
as soon as the peer reviewers give it a
thumbs up it goes straight to uh
production
for you know any typographical errors
and layout and that kind of thing
instead
the editor
came back to me and said we have these
content changes that we need you to make
before your paper can be printed and i
was like
what
aren't the peer reviewers the ones who
are supposed to be the arbitrators of
the content of the article but no they
wanted me to remove every reference i
had
to people with melanin rich skin in
other words people who have a naturally
darker toned skin
having increased risk for vitamin d
deficiency
and that's a scientific fact
yeah and i said that would be perfectly
immoral if i knew that this was causing
a certain group of people to be higher
risk and i refused to tell them because
i wanted to be politically correct no i
cannot do that that's a deal breaker
i will just i can
rearrange the sentences you know i can
tone it down in other ways but i can't
just omit that fact the peer reviewers
accepted it with that information i
believe that information is critical
to high-risk individuals and i won't
remove it and eventually they back down
but it was it was you know a standoff
there where
you know my husband and i prayed over it
and we had made a conscious decision of
you know are we going to after all this
work
allow this article to die on this hill
and we said no this is a hill i'll die
off
we have
a number of uh stories of censorship i
mean everybody's experienced censorship
on social media and twitter and now
linkedin if they've tried to share
things about vitamin d i actually have a
friend who works for facebook and i who
personally reversed some uh articles
that i was sharing that got got censored
by facebook but that's fortunate that i
know somebody there but my the second
version of our causal influence
paper was rejected by med archive which
is a pre-print server right so
pre-prints aren't supposed to judge
content
they're supposed to they have certain
safeguards which is fair enough but the
the reason for rejecting the paper was
that we used we added new use of so
causal language
in a causal inference study and they
refused to uh publish it and and said
they wouldn't publish it unless we
changed removed that wording and
replaced it with phrases like is
associated with which is exactly the
opposite of what we were trying to what
we've proven in the study wait wait wait
wait wait so there must be something
wrong with our
zoom call because it sounded almost
exactly like you said
that there was censorship
discussing vitamin d with respect to
covid
and happening in pre-print not just it
also happens in journals with a
colleague uh if you can use the word
colleague in an associate through this
community a few months ago shared
uh he'd had several it's a
well-respected professor of um
epidemiology and vitamin d expert and
he's had three rejections
of a paper that he was
a positive paper about vitamin d
two of the replies
told him to change the finding to a
negative finding or they wouldn't
publish the paper so
it's over it is overt but this is this
is what i'm having such a hard time
conveying to anybody who is only loosely
paying attention to what's going on with
our public health response to covet
is that
when somebody says
that discussion of the effect of vitamin
d and vitamin d deficiency on kovid is
being censored on social media platforms
they've said something utterly
remarkable
this is
a very important
factor in kovid
and i will ask you shortly to talk about
the
um
[Music]
an estimate of how much of the death
that has flowed from covid could have
been prevented if people had been aware
of the vitamin d issue and had
dealt with it but
to the extent that vitamin d
is extremely safe
extremely
cheap
and apparently extremely effective
at preventing covid
when you are
widely available i mean
[Music]
stacks of it at costco you know that are
taller than i am i it's amazing what a
simple
easily accessible intervention
this is
and
the fact that it differentially i mean
even your story linda about
your being told to change language about
populations having different
susceptibility to deficiencies in
vitamin d
who will be harmed by that people who
are likely to be vitamin d deficient who
won't necessarily know about it unless
someone has mentioned it so
even even this is upside down but there
is another group of people that will be
harmed by that
because the narrative was
that the reason why
dark complected people who were not
living along the equator
were
having more hospitalizations fatalities
and deaths from covet 19 was because of
health disparities
and that drove a huge influx of funds
into
public clinics and that sort of thing
that all of that funding was dependent
upon the idea that we had now proven
that health disparities were killing
people
now i
originally thought that might be the
case
until
the uk telegraph
published their wall of heroes of the
first people who had died
of covenanting the first healthcare
professionals who had died of coca-19
the first 10 physicians to die of kevin
19 in the uk
were all
dark complected people who were
immigrants or their ancestors were
immigrants to the uk
and
just uh shortly after that wall started
being published it was up to 90 of all
the people who died in the uk who were
health care professionals including
uh or any any health association at all
we're dark complected now you cannot
tell me that a neurosurgeon who happens
to be of indian origin
died of covid because he couldn't get
access to basic care
that is not why he died it was not a
health disparity issue right that so
this is i mean
the problem is that the simple facts of
the way information is being treated
here
if you look at it and you acknowledge
its implication it makes you sound like
a crazy person right we have an
intervention i mean
we can talk all day about repurposed
drugs and whether they do or don't work
and what the evidence says and whether
randomized controlled trials are the
answer or whether they're obscuring the
answer
but this is vitamin d
and you know i must say i've been using
it as a bellwether the very fact that we
are still not recommending vitamin d to
people in
high latitudes who are almost certainly
deficient given the evidence is an
indicator that something that to my mind
goes beyond
anything that could be explained by
incompetence is just very clear and
for you to encounter in the publication
process that some
sensitivity about interrupting some
narrative about health disparities which
as far as i'm concerned probably do
exist but even figuring out to what
extent they are explanatory requires a
discussion of what other things might be
leading to some portion of uh the
disparity and outcomes that we're seeing
so the idea that we know the conclusions
and that we are going to dress them up
as science and then provide them to the
public and in so doing by the way
prevent people from having the
information about vulnerabilities they
themselves may harbor right we're yeah i
mean my my african-american friends and
my jamaican friends and my ghanaian
friends are angry
that
that this censorship is occurring
because they're saying you know they are
so
yes we all admit there are health
disparities but they are so focused on
this narrative and on this end game that
they have their political agenda that
they are willing to risk the lives of me
and my friends over their agenda and
that just makes me mean that makes me
very angry and at the same time
i mean i i am just struck by the fact
that
we have
operation warp speed
to produce
vaccines
at an incredibly rapid pace an
impressive feat no matter what you think
of the product that was produced is an
impressive feat that they got there so
quickly but what have we done we have
sped
the process of
safety testing which is something that
cannot be accelerated it's not a matter
of something you can do faster because
in part what you're looking for are
delayed effects
so what we've got is a system that
pretends that it is so obsessed with
your health that it is going to cut
corners in your interest in order to get
you to something that works as rapidly
as possible
at the same time
it is ignoring something that clearly
does work
that is clearly very safe and would be
the number one intervention i mean in
fact
my viewers will know that i have uh
a
i think well-founded obsession with the
concept of diminishing returns that this
is the most important thing to
understand with respect to complex
adaptive systems
uh which is that there are some
interventions that are highly effective
and very easy and then you exhaust those
and you move towards things which do
less and less at a greater and greater
expense and the point is vitamin d is at
the very most bargain level right the
amount of good that could be done
for the smallest amount of intervention
is probably vitamin d
and yet somehow we're up here at some
risky experiment that we're running with
some very novel technology that is
claimed to be safe but obviously there
are indications that it might not be so
safe
in terms of efficacy we know that six
months down the road it has
spectacularly
dropped off so we're dealing with some
super exotic remedy here when there's a
very basic remedy that we're pretending
doesn't exist this makes
no sense the level of financial
commitment early on
to
vaccines was so high
and for the you know for the right
reasons at the beginning of the pandemic
we didn't know what we were dealing with
you know it could have been something
far worse than
than code 19. um but once you've
committed to a financial
route that's worth what trillions and
who knows how much that's worth yeah i
think just the very idea that something
as simple and cheap and widely available
as vitamin d
could be
the solution would then lead to having
wasted all of that money and all the
operational setup and i think
at some level whether it's cognitive
bias unconscious cognitive bias or
whether it's
conscious pernicious manipulation by the
people who are making the trillions of
dollars or both it's probably all of the
things that you can think of
um
that that just led to people not not
wanting to even try because you've
mentioned pascal's wager before even if
we were wrong we knew we were one but
even if we were wrong
means he's good for so many things
why wouldn't you just on the balance of
risks say you know we know it's safe up
to at least four thousand international
units uh actually the studies show
itself but higher than that and
thousands of
there's no one who says that less than
10 000 is harmful that more that 10 000
or less right it's like why wouldn't you
just do that as a blanket recommendation
to every adult
and then
you know see if it works yes the uh i've
started to think about it this way which
is when one
recommends an intervention one has to
think very carefully about the side
effects right and in this case the side
effects are largely positive right the
side effects will be that people will be
more resistant to other diseases
and so the point is look let's say
somehow you two have
completely misunderstood the evidence
right i've read your work i know that's
not what happened but let's say that
somehow you had misunderstood the
evidence about what was going on with
the interaction of vitamin d deficiency
and covin
then still the recommendation
would be a slam dunk with respect to
improving human health generally with a
minimal safe intervention
if you add on top of that the incredibly
powerful evidence that this is an
incredibly important factor in the harm
that has come from covid and the point
is
no rational person who was actually
interested in controlling this disease
and had looked at this evidence could
possibly have failed to make this
recommendation
well i think there's something we're not
taking into account obviously people
aren't rational
uh but um
but but there's something else you're
not taking into account and that is that
most people like to perceive themselves
as being intelligent heroes and that's
true of our public health officials as
well
and basically if they accept the vitamin
d
evidence that we've provided them now
they had been duped by
previous
things and they're not heroes at all
because they should have recommended
this a year ago a year and a half ago
and so they'd be replacing their
superheroes cape with a dunce cap and no
one wants to do that well the hardest
person to
convince of something is the person who
has been
uh conned basically good so let's hope
they watch my podcast
because i i think of myself as something
of an expert at getting less dumb over
time right and the key lesson here is
that if you have been dumb
and you're confronting the question of
admitting that you've been dumb it's
still a bargain because continuing to be
dumb makes the cost go up and getting
smart as quick as possible is really no
matter how late in the process no matter
how i mean look i've told you already
when kovitz started i would have told
you hey you need to be a bit careful
supplementing vitamin d because it's a
fat soluble vitamin and that means
there's a hazard of overdose so we want
to figure out exactly what that level is
you know what
that was dumb that was an extrapolation
from vitamin a and it was not justified
and it presumably has had some effect on
my thoughts about whether or not it
would be a good idea to supplement
vitamin d who knows how many respiratory
viruses i have suffered from or suffered
worse than i might have because i've
been deficient in vitamin d for my whole
life but you know what
i'm not going to do that going forward
yeah you're a scientist brad and we're
scientists i mean linda and i i you know
we have many conversations
where we've both
said i'll change my mind immediately i
currently believe this but as soon as
there's new evidence i'll change my
position the three of us are scientists
that's what we do we know we're trained
to do that but i don't think politicians
unless they're scientists have that
mindset and they tend to double down
yeah but you know what you you said
something in passing a few minutes ago
which unfortunately uh fits the evidence
all too well which is that there's a
perverse incentive here for many
people there's a gigantic market that
has opened up as a result of covid and
if you imagine
sociopaths or robots running the public
health apparatus and i'm not saying that
that's what's going on but just use that
as a model for a moment and you imagine
that their purpose was to enhance their
own position in the world
right
and that these markets were suddenly uh
spitting out cash at an incredible rate
right well then
what would they think of
repurposed drugs that work like
flavoxamine or
vitamin d which is available you know by
the pallet full at your box store
right what would they think if these
things suddenly loomed up and threatened
to control covet and
put the world back to normal yeah and as
a result of that we've actually had some
vitamin d proponents who are offering a
different message
there's a really nice very elegant
little study that was done
um came out in december of 2020 but it
didn't talk about cover 19 at all
that looked at immunization's effects on
the elderly and showed that
if someone is who's elderly has very low
vitamin d and they're immunized
then when they look at their skin for
anti antibodies they find that they
don't have a strong
reaction to
the vaccination and they have a much
better reaction to the vaccination if
they have higher vitamin d levels then
they took the people who had the poor
reaction supplemented them with vitamin
d
and found that their reaction improved
and so even if you don't think vitamin d
has anything directly to do
with
kova 19
then you should at least be supporting
at this point the public health people
should at least be supporting vitamin d
as an adjunct to the immunizations
because you're more likely to get a good
response to that third or fourth or
fifth booster
if you have a higher vitamin dealer
so
what i'm beginning to understand and you
know my my expertise is
complex adaptive systems what i'm
beginning to understand that i didn't
understand before
is that the term
vitamin
is
not especially helpful then
right and so in effect
i'm i'm uh thinking by analogy to the
term catalyst
applied to an enzyme right well yeah
vitamin d actually is its primary role
and i've only learned this more recently
i didn't know this a year ago but its
primary role is in altering cell
signaling both within the cell and
between cells
so the main thing that vitamin d does is
it improves communication throughout the
body
and the reason why we call it
pre-hormone is
is because
a hormone is something your body makes
whereas a vitamin is by definition
something your body does not make
so calling vitamin c calling it vitamin
d when your body makes it doesn't make
any sense
this i didn't know vitamin so when we
say essential amino acid what we mean is
essential in your diet because you can't
make it right correct when we say
vitamin we are saying something similar
this is something you can't make and
then vitamin d is clearly not a vitamin
right because vitamin d can be made by
your skin but vitamin d can also be
obtained from food and a lot of people
think that they can get enough from food
if they're careful enough and that is
not the case unless they're leading
a truly primitive lifestyle i've got
japan and eat fish every meal
well yeah like i said even then a lot of
people in japan are somewhat deficient
people in
norway and
and
iceland are less deficient because they
eat more fish so it needs to be cold
water fatty fish which are usually found
in deep water spaces like oceans so even
wild caught salmon is going to be high
in vitamin d
but farm-raised salmon is not because
the reason salmon are high in vitamin d
is because they get the vitamin d from
the plankton that they eat which sits
out in the sun
so um
i've got a friend that i spoke to just
two weeks ago who works as a or worked
previously as a family practitioner in a
remote area of alaska
and he said that he about 10 years ago
was testing every one of his patients
for vitamin d
and he could predict which one of his
patients
came from a villa they all came from
villages
but some of the villages retained their
native lifestyle so they were eating
mostly wild game and and fish
and those
people
had a vitamin d level of not just 50 but
60 to 80 nanograms per milligram
milliliter whereas those that had
adopted the westernized uh diet
they were almost universally severely
vitamin d deficient
so
all right yeah salmon wild got fashion
that's about all because if you know
when they talk about having vitamin d in
uh
fortified foods and vitamin d and
irradiated mushrooms but those levels
are so low
that they're pretty much insignificant
you get vitamin d in eggs but you would
have to eat 50 eggs a day to get enough
vitamin d for that day that's a lot of
things on respiratory illnesses is i
mean i've heard one doctor say there's
no such thing as
flu and cold season there's only vitamin
d deficiency season and as i use you
mentioned you know about wondering how
many coals and flu you might have
avoided in the three years that i've
been supplementing vitamin d
because i was diagnosed diagnosed
deficient and i used to get colds and
flu every year i was the kind of person
that would just catch everything i
haven't had a single
noticeable
cold i mean i've had sniffles start i
feel it coming on
and uh i just haven't had a cold or flu
i've had cove it but it was like
one degree temperature for about a day
and a half a little dry cough and i've
recovered and i've recovered from
everything within it always resolves
within a day yeah in fact
my interest in
vitamin d began
uh the first time i heard
ryan cole dr ryan cole
talk about it and he said exactly this
he said there is no cold and flu season
there's vitamin d efficiency season and
it was a dime dropped for me it was like
yeah many people that work that are part
of our community the email community are
retired doctors who somehow discovered
this mindy despite their training and
and have been using it with their
patients there's a famous um
paper about something called the d3
hammer which is um i think it's a dose
of 50 000 international units that a
doctor used on uh geriatric patients to
resolve
flu and cold symptoms and and said
they've resolved within two days uh and
people have been using that i also find
and we discuss a lot of nutritional
support um
protocols uh it works in concert with
this means c and zinc so
uh the moment i think i'm you know might
be subject to a cold or flu i also make
sure to take vitamin c and i'm taking
vitamin d every day
and and yeah never felt healthier it's
um
and that's that's a very common story
among our community you know we're very
very robust in terms of colds and flu
i think this whole idea of flu sees
colder and flu season being in the
winter when i was a child they used to
say oh yeah it's because everyone is
indoors and and that worked back when i
was a child because i'm so very old that
we didn't have air conditioning when i
was a child growing up but that no
longer is a satisfactory explanation now
because most people in europe and the
united states and canada live in
climate-controlled homes
and how much we are in close proximity
with other people has nothing to do with
the time of year at all
and so the fact that we have a cold and
flu season in the winter cannot possibly
be a result of us being indoors more in
the winter because it's cold because
in texas we're outside more in the
winter because it's nice and cool and in
the summer we're all together in our
air-conditioned places because it's too
hot to be outside
there's been a there's been a false
assumption i think forever that the
seasonality is down to things like
behavior movement etc hanging out but
also the effect of uv destroying viral
particles in the open air
and that was something that i looked at
early on because it is definitely
responsible for reduced transmission
rates you can see how that would dampen
transmission rates but what it doesn't
explain is why case fatality rates would
vary over the seasons and most
scientists and doctors assume that it
doesn't most assume that the case
fatality rate is fixed it was one of the
first things i looked at it's very easy
to separate those two things out you
just look at the ratio
of recovery to hospitalizations and if
that's varying or into the season you
know the case fatality rate is changing
and it was and it was changing not just
over time in particular regions you
could see the geographic relationship so
case fatality rates were much much lower
in hotter countries where they were
in this you know on the other side of
the planet in australia it was in summer
i still can't believe that australia's
in lockdown i mean they have
zero reason almost zero cases i mean
fewer cases across the entire continent
of australia than we have in my borough
in london
well yeah
it's almost as if uh you know
tyranny was the point and
covid was the excuse
but certainly
were one looking to preserve the
freedoms in the glorious free society
like australia
turning to something like
vitamin d
would be a much wiser thing to do
um
than to lock down civilization and they
generally don't have the the problem
that we do because
they're further towards the equator than
than we are and that's why they have a
very low incidence of um well of covered
and covered deaths uh finland is also
another really good example as well as
japan japan has naturally higher vitamin
d status than we do and had a much much
milder pandemic than we did and finland
is a an incredible country to look at
because they've implemented
a nationwide food fortification with
vitamin d and they did they started it
in 2003 they doubled it in 2010 and if
you look at the cdc data
historically for
influenza virus
particles of different different
mutations you can see the drop in the
entire in line with the vitamin d
fortification because they had a
terrible problem which is why they put
the program into into place in the first
place
if you look at uh the scandinavian
countries the exception that's always
brought up is sweden early on had was
really hard hit with covet but if you
look at the
you go dig down deep into the data what
you find is
several sweden is different from the
other scandinavian countries in several
ways one is that they're more likely to
have their elderly and care homes uh but
and they do have somewhat lower vitamin
d uh deficiency and somewhat higher
vitamin deficiency but the interesting
thing is is their initial weight when
they were hit so hard
was all was 50 of the people who died
were somali immigrants
and you know the somali refugees who of
course are dark complected people who
are not eating the native diet of fish
and
represent less than one percent of the
population
and so this group of people
who didn't have the vitamin d
and who was out of their normal element
and therefore weren't getting vitamin d
from the sun
uh
were
getting via getting coco 19 and everyone
was saying oh yeah it's because sweden
isn't locking down
okay so could you could you
run through that statistic again what
fraction of the swedish deaths the the
very early data not not to this day but
the early data in sweden fully 50 of the
people who died were somali refugees
despite the fact that they represent
less than one percent of the population
so
they would have had two
extra
risk factors one coming from not eating
the native fish rich diet and the other
coming from dark skin that blocks the
production of vitamin d
through photosynthesis
exactly and there are really good
studies in maternal health because
maternal health is strongly related to
vitamin d
and a lot of maternity centers test for
vitamin d and provide vitamin d
supplements and the if you look at
articles about the somali refugees in
sweden
you find that
that group of people was extremely
vitamin d deficient but they're very
reticent to take vitamin d supplements
because their imams would tell them that
they were
going counter to allah if they were not
just continuing with the traditional
ways and so it was very difficult to get
these somali refugee women to accept
vitamin d supplements
wow
all right so
so again my
my model of vitamin d was wrong vitamin
d is not a simple cofactor that is
involved in important uh
reactions in which most of us get enough
from our diet and some of us may be
deficient and so a little bit of
supplementation would bring you up to uh
up to the right level and you would have
whatever protection
that turns out to be wrong this is not a
vitamin by the definition that you
provided
it is apparently highly relevant to many
different functions in the body the
importance of it in cell to cell
signaling is of course
conspicuous because that's going to have
tremendous ramifications around the body
potentially
um and
i would also say i think i was misled
because
like so many
i took the
usrda
uh
recommended daily allowance to be
indicative of at what point deficiency
would kick in if you were below the
usrda you were probably deficient if you
were above it you probably weren't and
therefore had very little to gain from
uh supplementing or thinking about it
and what i believe i've come to
understand from your paper
is that in fact the recommended daily
allowance is actually
a kind of paleolithic measure built
strictly around its implication for
bone density in addition there's a
statistical error that's been pointed
out by two different statisticians and
uh confirmed by a third
that that says that the uh amount of uh
the the usrda
is off
by a factor of close to 10. it's not
just a decimal error movement it's a
more complicated statistical error than
that
but the uh usrda
should probably be closer to 7 000
international units rather than 400 to
800 international units wow um so the so
that and and i don't know why they have
not revisited that to see about changing
that but vitamin d affects a lot more
than just your immune system
and everything that vitamin d affects if
you compare
the symptoms of vitamin d deficiency
with the symptoms of severe covet 19
they match up almost perfectly so for
instance
just getting covet 19 in the first place
vitamin d strengthens the epithelial
junctions the tight junctions the gap
junctions the junctions between cells so
you're less likely to have an invader
such as the stars the stars co2 virus
even enter the system
if you have vitamin d levels high your
your basically your your walls
surrounding your city will be
strengthened by having good vitamin d
and so a lot of people are not ever
going to even test positive if they've
got a good vitamin d level
then your t-cell immunity is
strengthened and controlled so you're
more likely to have an appropriate
reaction
to the invader rather than having an
overreaction where you you know burn all
your powder too quickly and then don't
have anything left or you do
catastrophic damage to yourself because
you're just shooting wildly um
so vitamin d helps with the adaptive
immunity as well as the innate immunity
and then it also controls um
some complicated things that we don't
need to go into like the
renin-angiotensin system
and
so there are other
more complex
systems within the body that go out of
control
in covet 19 that vitamin d helps
regulate and keep in control and one of
the things that's gotten a lot of press
lately has been the fact that with
severe cover 19 you get thrombolytic
events you get blood clots that do a lot
of damage in fact most of the damage
from severe covet 19
is
not just damage in the lungs but also
you get damage in the various other
organs because of blood clots and those
blood clots aren't formed by the virus
itself they're caused by the
overreaction to the the virus
and vitamin d controls that system and
helps prevent those blood clots
fascinating and then the number of
mechanisms that were already known
pertinent to
this particular disease i mean i'm i've
got a document i think i'm i'm running
up to nearly 10 that i know about now
there are dozens and vitamin d is well
known to
control i think now more than 20 000
genes in the body so it's it's it's one
of the most ubiquitous and uh and
important hormones of all of the
hormones i mean every hormone is
important but it's uh and i think it's
probably worth clarifying that the
d3 version that we eat is several
metabolic steps away from the active
form and what we measure when we call
the active form actually isn't the
active form there's another one another
step further down so you'll hear calcium
calcifidiol
is as the active form but it's actually
calcitriol which is the form that's used
in cells to initiate all of the immune
responses um
that that help you
with vitamin d but the mechanisms are
really well understood i've written
about the many other researchers have
written about them um and says really
baffling to understand why people would
question given the level of evidence
coming i mean the triangulation
you can get if you look at this from all
the different angles from biological
plausibility from
uh
temporal
the all of the geographic data around
the world ecological studies
longitudinal studies
you know there's four decades of
research behind vitamin d that's just
being ignored
um and part of it's snobbery because
it's food science you know there's a
historic
uh weight around vitamin d's leg part of
it is i think
i mean the the
literature's littered with statistical
mistakes and bad analyses and things
like that which don't help but if you
have a good grounding in stats and
understand numbers and data it's pretty
easy to clear the fog away and see that
see the real picture that's there
well i do think that we can
excuse a lot of the doctors who are not
on board with vitamin d because
they don't have the time most of them to
dig into the
the basic literature themselves they
rely upon their medical societies and
and the the various guidelines you know
up to date and the various guidelines in
order to get their information
and
about 10 years ago or so
the vitamin d clarion call was very loud
and this the time when my friend in
alaska was testing every single patient
for vitamin d
and
vitamin d
testing at that time was covered by
medicare and groups like that but what
happened is after that they did these
population studies
in which they used the usrda as the
amount of vitamin d they were going to
supplement with there were very poorly
designed studies with a very
uh
primitive understanding or not a very
adequate understanding of how vitamin d
works and so they supplemented people
with way less vitamin d than they should
have
they supplemented them for a shorter
amount of time than they should have
and they
supplemented people who were already
vitamin d sufficient as well as people
who were deficient and so that would
dilute the uh results and so it'd be a
little bit like i the example i give is
um we all know that amoxicillin uh is
extremely effective against strep coat
to this day we don't have severe
resistance for amoxicillin against strep
throat that's what everybody uses 500
milligrams three times a day is the
accepted dose if we instead
gave people in a study five milligrams
of amoxicillin three times a day and
then had another group which we didn't
give any amoxicillin at all we could
easily prove that amoxicillin is not
useful at all for strep throat and so
they basically disproved vitamin d being
useful
with studies that inadequately dosed
people and were poorly designed and
those studies were very widely accepted
and as a result
the
physicians were given the message oh
this vitamin d thing looked good
but we've disproven it it's really a
bunch of nothing and so a lot of the uh
physicians now when they hear about
vitamin d they say i'll fool me once
you're not going to fool me twice i know
this vitamin d thing is just a few
zealots it doesn't really work
and um
martinu did a study in 2017 that's
probably the most widely cited study for
vitamin d
in which what he did was he took all the
studies
that had been poorly designed
from uh
vitamin d
uh
going back and did a meta-analysis in
which he looked at individual patient
data
it was a massive study and showed with
this meta-analysis data that oh but if
you use high enough doses and you don't
give the boluses but rather you give it
daily or weekly you do get a dramatic
effect on uh respiratory viruses in fact
respiratory viruses in the elderly are
cut in half
influenza rates death rates could be cut
in half with vitamin d supplementation
and that did get some attention
so uh
that study to me the big takeaway on it
is you have to look at the studies and
see whether or not they were designed
appropriately to get meaningful results
right or
as we've seen in some of the coveted
literature
there is a
a go-to move if you want to avoid the
impression that something works the
underpowered study and so i don't know
in the case that you cite whether or not
treating with
such a meager dose of vitamin d in a
population that may already be
sufficient was
intentional sabotage or simply an
accident but the fact is it is all too
possible
to generate the impression that
something highly effective isn't
effective at all if you design the study
in such a way that it doesn't reveal the
effect
that's right
so underpowered studies i'm looking at
the evidence i mean i've noticed this
phenomenon over and over again people
will and in fact nice did this when they
looked at the
they first did their review which you
know at the time i think i counted 8 000
results on google scholar for vitamin d
and coronavirus and then they came out
with a review that looked at five
studies they actually did put our paper
in an appendix of studies that they
wouldn't consider because it was a
pre-print um although martino then
applied for some grant funding using it
so it was good enough for him to apply
for money uh but not good enough to tell
the world that you know this windy was a
thing to do um but
the
if if you i use a a metaphor which is a
if you have
detectives you've got some good
detectives and some bad detectives and
you tell them to investigate a murder
and five of them go to the house and see
the murder weapon and so find the blood
and the victim and the other five go
down to the pub or look in their kitchen
or in their own you know their own or
have a beer or whatever they're gonna
come back with different reports some
are because of incompetence and laziness
uh and some might be just corrupt you
can't take five studies that show strong
evidence and then five studies that
didn't provide evidence and somehow say
there's no evidence studies cancel out
the positive evidence from the first
five but very often in the literature
and i think this is true in medicine in
general
studies that report ever no evidence of
effect are immediately interpreted as
evidence of no effect which is a
completely different statement and you
need you can
make a study that can prove there's no
effect within a certain tolerance but
you have to have incredibly high power
i'm not aware of any study that's done
that
the hasty biobank study claimed to have
done it but that was statistical fiction
linda and i collaborated with the
physicists to take down that paper and
point out that they've they've just
artificially inflated they had about a
thousand data points and they they
claimed it they had nearly half a
million by mislabeling all of extra
i've never read a worse piece of science
in my life i don't know how that got
published
um it just shows how broken peer review
is and the number of studies that quote
that study the reason we went to the
trouble of rebutting it formally was
because people were still quoting it a
year later and it's it's
blatantly wrong and and i don't
understand how anyone could read it and
take it seriously but it's it's taken
seriously all the time
yeah we we see this pattern uh across
the covid literature
and um
it's very well let's put it this way you
know the story is well we don't have
enough evidence that
vitamin d or ivermectin
uh works and therefore we're advising
caution because of the danger of using
it well what if there is no danger
because these things are comparatively
safe well there is a danger and then you
look into the evidence of that and it
isn't really evidence but then
you see something like flavoxamine right
which has now been demonstrated to be
highly effective against cobot and
there's no move uh
evident to make it the standard of care
so the point is well
it seems like actually you don't want
things that work to be used because and
you're just using the fact that you
don't think the evidence is good enough
to explain why you're not using these
things and the way we can tell is that
when you have something that does meet
your standard of evidence you still
don't use it right so
sometimes the sometimes the politics get
in the way and the politics are just
unbelievable if you look at what's
happened with monoclonal antibodies in
the united states monoclonal antibodies
have been around and have been had
emergency use use authorization they're
very expensive but they didn't work
since january
of 2021 but very few states were using
them and they weren't very well
publicized well the governors of texas
and florida
you know the two states that are
flouting a lot of the uh
uh restriction lockdown kind of things
both highly endorsed monoclonal
antibodies and started opening up
monoclonal antibodies centers so that
anybody who wanted them could easily
access monoclonal antibodies so what
happens next
monoclonal antibodies
are
suddenly um
regulated the distribution becomes
regulated by the federal government and
they start
and they forbid the companies from
shipping to florida or texas because
they say we need to distribute these
equitably across all the states so these
states that aren't interested in
monoclonal antibodies have stockpiles of
them while texas and florida are shorted
which even if they were to distribute
those and use them this will prevent you
from accumulating the evidence that they
work right if texas and florida start
allowing anybody who wants monoclonal
antibodies to use them
and they suddenly have low rates of
covet harm from people who have been
infected then that would raise the
question of whether the rest of the
state should get on board on the other
hand if you distribute these things in
such a way that the effect is diluted
and nobody has a very strong effect
because they're so widely distributed
you won't see that pattern and you can
uh dismiss dismiss this potentially
important
curative agent uh and you know basically
rationalize your failure to use it yeah
and the whole thing is you've got
something that's very
strongly preventative
for severe copa 19 hospitalizations and
death whether it's vitamin d ivermectin
monoclonal antibodies whatever then you
lose the rationale for emergency use
authorization for the vaccines the
vaccines would seem to happen
right it's and so we have this one
therapy which clearly the public health
authority has uh signed up for and uh
will entertain no evidence that it was
an error
um
and we have all sorts of other things on
the table from slovoxamine to vitamin d
uh to monoclonal antibodies which are
you know uh
just unable to get a proper
hearing
um
so i want to ask you and i know it's
hard to quantify but this is after all
your area of expertise
how much of the harm
that we are seeing from covid19 if we
tomorrow were to address
um
vitamin d deficiency and we were to get
as serious as possible about alerting
people to the problem alerting people to
their special vulnerabilities if they
have dark skin or they spend a lot of
time indoors whatever their
vulnerabilities may be
and we were to start distributing
vitamin d with the kind of
aggressiveness that we are currently
pushing vaccines
how much of the harm of covid19
could be reduced well that's the first
because i've given this a lot of thought
and even written articles about it and
the answer is all of it
so even
different
there would be lots of papers estimating
what percentage of deaths could be
prevented and they vary between 80 and
100 depending on
the approach used there's a recent paper
that targeted 50 nanograms per
milliliter that suggested that if we
could get everybody to that level uh
we'd go down to zero deaths but i look
at it from a slightly different
perspective
as a physicist
particularly with an understanding of
exponential processes and
this is a double exponential process uh
in a pandemic because you've got the
exponential process of viral replication
within the body and then you've got the
exponential process of the sort of macro
level of spreading through the community
and in any exponential process if you
can
add a prophylactic that lowers the
transmission rate so those are
effectively which everybody's now
familiar with which is nice if you can
push r below zero
uh which is pretty easy to do even if
you reduce our um by a small amount it
has a very big impact in terms of the
end number
uh when you're dealing with exponential
processes and the the effect of vitamin
d is so strong
that you would wipe out the
pandemic if everybody was sufficient
because there wouldn't be enough people
it's a bit like if you have excuse me
taking a drink of water to explain a bit
if you have
a dry fire
linda and i like to talk about trying
but embers and tinder um
exactly it's a very good analogy if
you've got a fire
or rather a fire that's about to be made
of dry tinder blocks that are all
stacked together
and you've got different strategies you
can use to stop that from catching fire
one is to move all the rocks apart
social distancing
or you can spray the wood uh to keep it
damp and then the fire doesn't catch and
vitamin d is basically like just keeping
the wood damp so that the fire doesn't
catch so even if it's a bit burning
somewhere if as long as you can get most
people to a healthy level of green where
the wood is green then the fire just
goes out naturally
so um
i believe i understood your explanation
the following way
you have two exponential processes
viral replication inside the body which
is going to be a correlate of how sick
you get
and you've got the exponential process
involved in the spread
and the point is vitamin d works in both
ways it causes the spread to be greatly
reduced and it causes the degree of
sickness to be reduced in individuals
and the combination of both of these
reductions
is enough to bring
uh are sufficiently below one that it
will eventually go extinct yeah and
that's what normally happens in seas in
in summer
the effects the combined effects of uv
destroying viruses in in the air plus
the
improved host response drives are well
below uh that value and then it dies out
until winter starts and then there's
always a pool of
viruses somewhere because you know it's
it's zoonotic and it's it's in different
animals and we don't know really which
species it crosses because the studies
that look at zoonotic transmission are
based on lab animals and
their host response is completely
different to wild animals or animals in
a food market in china you know you just
you really need to look at different
populations to understand that well
that's a very terrifying scenario that
you paint um you know well it's also why
the vaccine program is dangerous and and
and you know i'm not you know lymphoma
both pro vaccines in general as iu um
we've taken every vaccine under the sun
and will continue to do so as long as we
believe in vaccines against
diseases most people have never heard of
just vaccinated a few weeks ago but the
reason the program for zoonotic disease
is like or any respiratory disease which
easily transmits between species
the human population represents 10
of the total reservoir because it's in
wild animals it's in food markets and
chickens and
pigs you have swine flu we've had bird
flu
and you can't you're not going to
immunize all of those
animals as well so i've heard doctors
arguing that we need to get to 90
because that means that it's totally
controlled but if you then
you know
multiply without by 0.1
because we're only 10 of the total
population you see the fallacy of of
that argument we're never going to wipe
it out that way the only way we're going
to get rid of it is if we get our
um
our host response healthy and the way to
do that is through
good nutrition lifestyle
um and not you know not depending on
solutions that are expensive that don't
really work or that have a limited life
because evolution is very clever at
getting around
whatever technology we create to stop it
well again i i think this is a very
terrifying scenario i mean if you were
let's say in the pharmaceutical industry
and you were depending on this new
market to continue to allow you to i
don't know uh
pay the mortgage on your new boat or
whatever it is that's driving this but
um
but yes for the rest of us
it's a very delightful prospect that we
actually might have the tools at our
disposal to at least drive this down to
a level where it is um
extremely well managed the way we could
say of something like plague or rabies
in the first world where
we never encounter these things
but driving it extinct would be uh even
more delightful so
we have coronaviruses all the time and
most of them are completely innocuous
people get them and don't even realize
this one obviously everybody is is
treating as if it's something that's
always fatal and that just isn't the
case of course it kills people with
comorbidities very easily and we believe
that's because they're vitamin d
deficient it's not the only reason
i i think of it as the the sort of um
the breastplate of immunity you know you
can have other chinks in your armor that
go missing for whatever reason but if
the breastplate's missing you're wide
open you know it's just like just get
that in place make sure that's protected
and you'll probably be okay
now this virus is not going to go
extinct and this is one of the
frustrating things that i've seen with
the public health response is that they
keep on promising the public if you do
this if you do that if you do that
covenanting will go away as if
the fact that we are more virtuous as a
society somehow influences what this
virus is going to do the virus does not
care about whether or not you care about
your neighbors or not
the the virus just does what viruses do
and this particular virus has been found
in many animals including wild animals
anytime as soon as you discover
that a
virus is also has a animal reservoir you
know it will never be extinct smallpox
had no animal reservoir and that is why
we could drive it to be extinct so so
has no animal reservoir
yeah
reservoir it will never be
so i i wanna i wanna ask you about this
because i've been tracking this uh
pretty carefully and i'm very cautious
about saying we can't drive it extinct
because although that is quite possible
i don't know of the piece of evidence
that tells us that now it sounds to me
like you're
drawing a very clear line at if animal
reservoir then extinction is impossible
but
um the animal reservoir you must be
pointing to is
white-tailed deer
no there are that that's the problem is
there are multiple wild animals now hold
on
you may you may be telling me something
i don't know but
uh as far as i understand it we have
seen this virus uh move between
minks
and ferrets
but these are domestic populations
there's a single case as far as i know
of a mink that has shown that it has
contracted uh sars kovi ii but it was a
mink in close proximity to a domestic
population
um there are many
because in utah they have mixed two
multiple maps maybe no you may be
telling me something that's more up to
date than i know right are you telling
me
more than one
yes and once you get it into a wild
population
it can go
anywhere and you cannot possibly
immunize wild every wild animal and also
we haven't tested all the animals there
are too many to test so we only have a
very limited view of what's actually
happening in the real world right my
point would be we don't need to drive it
extinct we need to make sure that it's
not a threat and it can be if it can be
shrunk down into something that's no
longer scary and terrifying and doesn't
make people ill and doesn't do the
rounds every year which is absolutely
possible um then
uh we won't need to worry about it sure
i i agree with this completely i mean at
the level that we've got plague
controlled uh i think we could all
breathe information for example we deal
with influenza every year and i think
people probably don't realize we've
we've been vaccinating against influenza
since 1945 to what end i don't that
hasn't made a single dent in what
happens
uh globally it's just made a lot of
money for people who make those vaccines
and the vaccines are
frequently just part of why i was so
skeptical about these vaccines is
it's famous in
medical circles that the vaccine
efficacy that's touted by the trials
that are run on usually 1995 and some
years the actual real world efficacy is
as low as three percent
and it can vary by geography um so if
you if you don't need those vaccines and
instead you can help people by
making sure their immune system just
worked properly in the first place that
obviously is going to take a lot of a
huge industry out
and i think that's why we're seeing some
nefarious behavior trying to suppress
vitamin d messages and those those
actions have been going on for a very
long time i've i came into this uh march
2020 but i'm in touch as linda with
people who've been campaigning for more
than a decade and failing to get the
message
through for some reason and there's a
lot of
assumptions in that community that it's
because if people really knew the
vitamin d worked then many medicines
would suddenly be under threat because
it affects so many different diseases
it's not just covariates cancers it's
you know all sorts of
autoimmune diseases psoriasis
name a disease it's probably something
to do with vitamin d
i think it's important going back to the
basic messages of your dark horse videos
is it's important to say we're not
saying that vitamin d is the only thing
that you need to do to be healthy
vitamin d is a huge part of it and i
believe that if you know the studies
have shown that if your vitamin d level
is 50 nanograms per milliliter or above
your chances of getting cover 19 drop
down to a very municipal level and if
you do get it you're likely to get such
a mild case that you're not going to be
passing it along to anyone else
certainly not going to be hospitalized
and that kind of thing but i think it's
important to add to that that our modern
lifestyles have other reasons why we're
destroying our immune health
melatonin is recommended partly because
we look at screens too late at night and
we don't get enough sleep at night
and
not getting enough sleep is hard on your
immune system
in addition you need to eat a balanced
diet vitamin d is unique in that it is
the only thing that's called a vitamin
that you cannot get from a
healthy varied diet
people talk about zinc magnesium vitamin
c
uh omega-3 fatty acids
um
uh selenium and uh
you can look those up and and see
whether or not you're likely to be
deficient in those but for most people
they can get those things through their
food it depends you know for instance
selenium is available in the western
hemisphere not so much in the eastern
hemisphere um
zinc is available if you eat eggs or
meat but if you're a
vegetarian you might have trouble
getting it
magnesium is difficult to obtain if
you're an acid reducing medications
so
you have to look at your own personal
risk factors but vitamin d
almost everyone has a vitamin d
deficiency the only exception are those
people that
ruff mentioned earlier who have the
truly indigenous diet where they're
eating almost exclusively
uh
fresh caught fish or uh smoked fish
or
you know it's the cold water fatty fish
or fresh game other than that you're
likely to be deficient if i can just uh
put this back in in my framework
the the thing that distinguishes vitamin
d
in addition to its
broad implication in many different
processes in the body if i understand
you correctly both hormonal signaling
which is signaling between cells at a
great distance and cell to cell
signaling in within a tissue am i
correct it's implicated yeah and even
within the cell signaling
it's not just endocrine which is the
hormone the hormonal right so uh that's
one thing that distinguishes it is its
relevance to a wide range of fundamental
processes the other thing that
distinguishes it is for people who have
the luxury of being able to eat
something like a
balanced diet a diet that looks more
like an ancestral diet we don't tend to
have deficiencies vitamin d is the
exception because this isn't the
mechanism through which our ancestors
got vitamin d the mechanism the
ancestors got it from is the sun and so
the model that yes i should behave more
like my ancestors in this regard because
it will mean i won't be deficient in
things that are important that model is
right but the problem is it isn't
through diet because of the unique way
vitamin d comes to us yeah you want to
live like your ancestors you have to
move to the equator and not wear clothes
and be outside all day
right or or you you know uh
or or gain weight all if you live
farther north you also don't wear many
clothes and and gain weight throughout
the summer until the ear you kill the
winter and gain muscle mass as you work
hard and then in the winter allow your
muscles to atrophy and your weight to
all come off of you as you gradually
come close to circulation until spring
one theoretical way to do it um i would
point out that uh in heather and my
recent book a hunter-gatherer's guide to
the 21st century we basically argue that
there are lots of places that going back
to a previous way of existing is
impossible for us moderns but there's
generally a way you can modify
uh your modern life to restore the
health that would derive from it and so
you know having the d minder app or some
other app on your phone that tells you
when uh is a good time to make vitamin d
and then deliberately exposing yourself
to the sun and banking that vitamin d
uh during the summer
is a good mechanism and then
supplementing during the winter so that
uh you correct for the the under
production
survival
further north of 40 degrees i would
recommend take supplements all year
round but just take more during winter
because modern lifestyle just doesn't
expose you to enough sun even if you
wanted to you know even if you're in in
the sun you generally just don't get
enough to get your levels up and keep
them up um but earlier you you asked
about the
you know how the i think the balance of
risk really between
exposing yourself to sun which is
a cancer risk so there's that's got to
be weighed up against
the uh the benefit of vitamin d so um
you know moderate amounts of sun you
don't want to burn for sure right it's
safer to get it through
uh the oral form but it is better to get
it you so you it takes several weeks to
raise your serum levels if you take it
um orally uh in pill form but if you get
it from the sun full body exposure you
can raise your serum levels in a few
hours i believe so if i only discovered
two days ago i didn't actually know that
so
so uh i i the yeah the elephant in the
room is the uh melanoma issue and you
know what's always the the pushback when
you say oh we need to spend more time in
the sun is oh but what about melanoma
and grassroots health has done some
excellent studies on that as have some
other people there's some good published
documents that show
that the problem with melanoma is not
exposure to the sun it's exposure to too
much sun too soon
so
if you don't get enough sun exposure to
burn
you just get enough sun exposure so you
develop a little bit of pinkness that
goes away as soon as you go indoors
that does not pose a higher risk to
melanoma and in fact the people with the
higher vitamin d levels even if they
achieve it from the sunlight rather than
from supplementation have a lower
melanoma rate than the people
who have a lower vitamin d level because
vitamin d
regulates your immune system and helps
protect you from all cancers including
melanoma so the way you get melanoma is
actually that your sun is shy
you don't have any tan at all and then
you go out and
binge on your spring break
beach trip and and blizzard yeah and and
burn and that's those are the people who
are more susceptible to melanoma so the
way to avoid melanoma is actually to
control your level of exposure to vita
to uh vitamin d from the sun
so that you increase your tolerance
without ever burning yeah but it's also
important for people to be aware that
you can
completely uh expose yourself to the sun
enough to get a tan and burn and still
get no vitamin d
if you're at the wrong time of day or if
you're working on location or wrong time
of year
because it's it's this tiny amount of
the range uh
about 300 nanometers of wavelength of
uvb
the target that specifically breaks
cholesterol and breaks this ring and
allows you to start synthesizing uh
the pro hormone um but that's just not
very available in sunlight it's it's
it's less than one percent of all uh all
uv actually so right so yeah that uva
that's giving your beautiful tan at 10
in the morning they're in oregon is not
going to give you an uvb
yep
so this is this is a this is a reason
yeah
well we generally recommend for healthy
adults take
4 000 international units
every day and you can take that all year
round i take more because i tested my
blood levels and i had even after taking
4 000 for 18 months i didn't reach
the minimum criteria of sufficiency so
something in my body isn't metabolizing
it well or digesting it well so i
actually take ten thousand and indeed
then try to take twenty thousand
um but but i don't recommend that as a
general recommendation for other people
if you if you're not sure test your
levels and find out
so i think there are uh
four recommendations that we can derive
from this
one
is
you might download an app that allows
you to figure out what sunlight is
useful and what is not so you can train
your mind to spot the useful moments in
the day where you are or you could make
vitamin d and alter your behavior with
respect to the sun in order to do it
without burning of course because that's
where your melanoma risk comes
from uh
two would be to supplement uh if you are
above 40 degrees latitude and probably
40 degrees latitude you said all year
round
um
but probably in light of the
safety of exposure to vitamin d
um and the potential benefits that come
from it airing in the direction of
assuming that you are deficient and
supplementing is probably the way to go
especially if your lifestyle keeps you
out of the sun and you wear sunblock and
things like that then you know you're
not going to be getting it from the
sunset yeah i would recommend that
anyone who can afford the two or three
cents a day that it is for vitamin d
supplements take them year round no
matter where they live because
uh anybody who's uh hearing this
recommendation is probably living a
modern lifestyle and just isn't taking
the time to get the consistent vitamin d
and vitamin d has to be produced
consistently because it doesn't have a
super long half-life
yep
um i think i said four
recommendations i only spot three at the
moment the third one
is to be suspicious of any public health
authority that is not recommending
vitamin d in the midst of a pandemic
against which this uh vitamin d is
clearly effective
i mean i i just don't especially when
they tell you that they take it
themselves but they won't recommend it
in public
yeah
right and we know that to be the case
here in the uk as well i mean you know
i've heard
that uh
yeah it's it's then drinking champagne
and telling the masses to drink water
it's uh
yes uh it is a stunning double standard
and you know the thing i have to keep
reminding myself of
is
the numbers here are so great we're
talking about
huge amounts of harm and death that are
coming from the absence of this
recommendation every day that this
recommendation is not out it is it is
causing families to find themselves
in grief at the loss of somebody who did
not need to die
and yeah uh it's unconscionable i i i
cannot believe that we are having a
podcast in which
the reality is this stark
and yet day after day one expects to see
the recommendation finally emerge
and it's just silence well you can
imagine the frustration that gruff and
i've had because both of us have been
dealing with this since 2020
for me it was february the end of
february there was actually a vitamin d
article in a ghanaian newspaper that i
read and it made me start looking and as
soon as i started looking i found all
kinds of good evidence for vitamin d and
i've just been so frustrated and wanting
to shake people i was like all these
people are dying for lack of knowledge
yeah why can't someone tell them the
truth and we wrote this vitamin d for
all thing and sent it to all the
government officials had people send it
to him we assumed that our word would
get out at least i thought surely
someone will pick up on this crickets
i've done podcasts in january all this
stuff so we're just so frustrated
that the message just doesn't seem to
get out so any of your listeners who are
hearing this
please
don't just take this for yourselves
share it with your friends your family
your co-workers anybody you can yeah so
there's another message an important
message that i'd like to um hopefully we
have a an audience that's already
receptive but you know if people were
cynical or skeptical at the beginning i
understand that i was i was probably
that person too about you know stories
like vitamin c and zinc because that
never worked to help my colds and flu
the magic edition of vitamin d that
finally did that
but i was very cynical and didn't
believe it at the beginning so that's
totally fine but you know pascal's wager
you know it's not harmful it's probably
good for lots of other things even if
you don't believe it
do take it seriously but if you look on
the internet
and google about vitamin d you will
almost certainly find
the negative studies are being
highlighted and promoted
the media have had a complete double
standard about we did get lots of very
positive coverage in the first year of
the pandemic from media
which was immediately then overturned by
the actions of the local health agencies
here in the uk who for reasons that
remain opaque to me
acted to suppress all of our messaging
uh there was a paper
released by susan and newest al who
um
use the word uh there are evidenced
health risks
for excessive vitamin d intakes and that
didn't provide any references
uh to back up that statement every other
statement in the paper is backed up with
citations but that one is conspicuously
absent of them and then recommend
against taking the levels that we
recommend and only taking the rda turns
out that susan lanham knew is also
a panelist and advisor on the um
the nutrition advisory committee in the
uk
so
very much i presume wanted to control
uh
maybe it was the not invented here
syndrome i think going on there
um
but
why
you know
the level of evidence is so vast now but
if you look on the internet you will
occasionally see
apparently negative studies and it's
important that we
uh
show people that they've been debunked
so if you read the biobank study by
hastier tal that was science fiction
we've and we published a letter you can
find it online that
goes into the
the
litany of errors that they made in that
paper but there are other studies for
example mendelian randomization or mr
studies you might read some of those
that apparently found
no evidence but
mendelian randomization just
couldn't find an effect
the
that particular technique just isn't
suitable for vitamin d i'm not going to
go into the details of why
but
um it's important to
just you know to be able to distinguish
the wheat from the chaff
yep i think it is also
it is very important that we
also extrapolate from this and i think
vitamin d is playing two roles in the
story and i want people to get both of
them one is
for your own well-being and for the
well-being of those that you care about
this is
the
cheapest safest most effective
intervention
and there's no reason to expose yourself
to more risk by remaining deficient when
you could remedy that
but the other thing is
once you look into this and if you have
doubts
we will have links to
your papers in the description take a
look at these papers
follow them look at the the studies that
say vitamin d has no effect and look at
the analysis of why those papers are
flawed see if you don't see the same
picture and if you do see the same
picture vitamin d is a highly effective
remedy
the side effects of
supplementing vitamin d are positive the
risk if somehow the analysis is wrong is
minimal
if all of those things are true
and public health authorities across the
world are failing to recommend this week
after week month after month as they are
disrupting civil liberties in order to
control the virus through social
manipulation in a way that isn't
effective
if that's all true
then what else are they not doing right
and start to look at all of the things
that you've been told
are
simply
clear in the evidence these things don't
work aren't an alternative etc and ask
yourself if they've got vitamin d wrong
how do i know that the things they're
telling me on these other fronts are
also not incorrect
good point very good and why uh why the
double standards why is
there a new antiviral that's got one
study right behind it suddenly being
approved by the fda
and
that's not which is which is
unprecedented i mean the single study is
never evidence for anything and yet you
know four decades of evidence behind
vitamin d
is being rejected
it doesn't make sense yeah why the
double standards the only reason to
explain that can be money it's got to be
being driven by profit
um so
yep i agree i agree with you the the
double standards across the board are
the indicator that this is about
something other than your health or
public health yeah and while the
government's still citing cases which is
a meaningless metric and has been since
the beginning you can't you can't give
enough context it's not even cases they
measure positive tests which is not the
same and the number of test changes but
they never divide by the number of tests
to tell you the fraction of positive
tests that's happening it's all scare
tactics
yeah
all right uh linda did you have one last
thing you wanted to say
no that's okay so all right
well uh
i think we've arrived at uh at the
natural conclusion here it's really a
very stark story um
i i know
people probably don't think vitamin d is
a very exciting topic but i think all
three of us and heather as well have had
the experience of happening on to this
story and then once you begin to see
just how central this is to the story
that is now controlling our lives and
has been for the last year and a half um
it's almost impossible to look away yeah
and i've heard that sentiment so many
times is once people wake up and see the
pattern it's impossible to unsee it you
see it everywhere and it suddenly
explains everything um we obviously saw
that back in march so it's been it's
been a long frustrating
maddening journey for us but it's a it's
a pleasure to finally uh have more
traction and people you know when when
we read
heather's
blog post and and the admission of your
change of mind of vitamin d it was a
very exciting day to for us because we
felt the um all the efforts of last year
had sort of petered out you know we did
so much good work
and there's a community of hundreds of
brilliant scientists working and doctors
working on this so we're very very
grateful that you're uh that you're able
to help us get the message out there uh
yeah one other thing that i had wanted
to say is that as your viewers look at
the evidence for anything with cover 19
they need to keep in mind that the
majority of journals
are uh
funded by advertising and the
advertising is almost exclusively coming
from big pharma and that is going to
influence the editorial policy it just
has to
oh and fact checkers are also funded by
pharma
that's true
and and even a journal that is open
source journal and most of its uh
funding that comes from the authors
is still in order to stay in that
community continue to be medline indexed
all those kinds of things there's a
cadre and you have to be part of that
culture to continue to have relevance so
there's a huge amount of pressure on
editors
to stay to continue to to uh uh draw
within the lines
yeah the the number of ways through
which the corruption affects what we
come to understand as uh
as scientific information is
many and i think the the lay public has
not been served well
by
the insistence
that the dictates of public health
authorities are simply uninflected
science
it's not the case and
it's time that in the interest of our
protecting ourselves from this disease
and every other that we
um
ushered pharma out of the path of sense
making so that we can begin to figure
out where we are and what works and how
to be healthier
yeah
all right
gruff linda this has been tremendous i
thank you so much for having us
it was really refreshing that you
allowed us to have so much time to speak
well it's really uh it's a it's a
remarkable story and i
i hope that people
hear it far and wide and they realize
how much of their medical well-being is
actually under their control here that's
really the the story that you've brought
to light and i'm very grateful for it
all right be well everyone thank you
bye-bye
[Music]
[Music]
you